zudem regnet es noch hallo mein name ist
luca herzlich willkommen zu einem
weiteren teil von die bio ich werde
heute versuchen meinen persönlichen
highscore aufzustellen ich weiß nicht
was meine bisherigen kurs waren aber ich
versuche besser zu sein ich hoffe
übrigens auch dass ihr nicht hört das
ist total regnet hört man dass ich will
fang an ich habe schon mal die bio
hochgeladen das verdanke ich euer alter
iw dr
der schießt die ganze zeit herum die ich
verlinke euch das video hier da könnte
draufklicken habe ich schon mal die bio
hochgeladen es geht darum ich kann diese
sachen hier abschießen und dann gehe ich
im level quasi voran also ich sammle
dadurch experience und kann dann wenn
ich mich vielleicht mal in ruhe lassen
oder so sehr über filter server
irgendwie werde ich die ganze zeit
abgeschlossen sein okay jetzt kann ich
nämlich unten links mal eingeben bundes
speedboot penetration und max mm hälfte
und jetzt kann ich ja schon mal so ein
bisschen stärker schießen kann ihn ja
mal abschießen und ich muss quasi sachen
abschießt und dadurch bekomme ich punkte
und dadurch kann ich mich verbessern das
ist der stil des spiels um gottes schon
krass ausgerüstet davon ob man diese
teile jahr abschließt bekommt man
beispielsweise ein bisschen mehr
experience wahlzeit dementsprechend
länger dauert die teile abzuschießen ich
hoffe nur dass das hinkriege das ding
absolvieren soll
so jetzt habe ich mich wieder zwei
sachen die ich hier verteilen kann wer
ist denn das da oben der so viele sachen
aussenden kann schön hier das blaue
abschießen so jetzt kann ich hier wieder
tausenden kugeln ausweichen hier meine
fresse könnt ihr euch niemand verpassen
alle von mir fight fight fight fight
fall ja ich habe jemand getötet hätte
penetration bundes damit schon wenn ich
jetzt davon ab schon bam bam ein paar
sekunden später erschien dann oh mein
gott okay okay okay ich bin heftig jetzt
mein gott ich bin schon krasser gewonnen
ich habe fast keine leben mehr um mein
gott nein nein nein lass mich in ruhe
das coole ist dass ich direkt bei der w7
eingestiegen bin war ich schon relativ
hoch war deswegen das ist immer ganz neu
ist dass man quasi nicht direkt bei null
anfangen muss aber ich möchte ich
trotzdem gerne töten bitte kann ich den
nicht vielleicht kann ich dich kann ich
dich okay geht nicht wie es der blauen
ab luca ja lass dir zeit genau der blaue
ist tot nehmen wir den nächsten blauen
und dann kann ich den blauen hier
nämlich auch schon taucht ad acta legen
dann habe ich die dämme ich kann ich
wieder ein paar mein gott ich werde
wieder von komischen sachen
abgeschlossen ich bin wieder eine
maschinen dann allerdings kommen von
überall sehr sehr große kügelchen
deswegen bin ich gerade so ein bisschen
mein gott wieder die teile die mich
verfolgen handy mal verpassen diese
komischen lila den ekelhaften fakten
nein nein nein ok ok go kam da und ok
kann da mein gott okay okay ich bin
wieder kurz vorm verrecken ich bin
gerade so kurz davor zu sterben alter
und ich bin was baronen ich hoffe echt
gehört das mit dem regen nicht mehr weil
es übel laut die scheiß es halt man kann
richtig schlecht hoch kommen weil alle
riesengroßen teilnahme die übels krassen
waffen und können an dass mein gott von
überall lass mich einfach nur in ruhe am
1 warum warum ich sterbe die ganze zeit
horn ist leicht respawnen wieder und
überall blöde leute zudem regnet sie
wieder rennens noch ja genau
genau wie komme ich jetzt auch komplett
egal hier komm ich mache sport damit ein
bisschen hoch ist als dichter und töte
ich jetzt weil das ist mir komplett egal
ob du ihr abgabe ist oder nicht das habe
ich auch mankell hat was als wenn als
wenn da schießt mich ruhig ab es macht
keinen sinn ich bin nämlich noch in
meiner einführungsphase das macht keinen
sinn so martin ott okay jetzt kann ich
jetzt gar nicht stemmen
oh mein gott überall rote punkte überall
baron lasst mich doch einfach in ruhe
man sie jetzt gerade erst das sicherheit
sachen von gegnern abschießen kann
menschen das komplette spiel hat jetzt
ganz anderen reiz für mich ja und jetzt
kommen sie von beiden seiten ich meine
sie einordnung ist ja nicht so als wenn
ich noch ein leben hätte im gegensatz zu
euch jetzt mal ein bisschen ruhe so hier
die sachen abschießen da abschließen
hier kann ich hier direkt maximum hält
bisschen hoch stellen wir euch beiden
noch abschießen hier den dann noch du
blöder doppel
ich habe schon mal geupdatet zum twin
jetzt gerade hier und habe jetzt schon
mal so ein paar mehr funktionen hat den
übelsten wolle damit schon übelsten
speed deswegen versuche ich jetzt
einfach mal der größte die bios spieler
zu werden der ich je war
die blöden dicht hätte ich doch direkt
bar du blöde kuh ich bin gerade echt
richtig gut dabei freunde du bist ja ein
richtig blöde hell freundlich muss das
video beenden an dieser stelle ich
steige jedes mal ein ich schwitze wie
sonst hat es faktisch nur ab immer wenn
ich gerade richtig gut beton alle
anderen an und deutlich so leicht
verbessert ein spiel gibt was mich
übelst dann ist es die bio mein gott
okay ich war ich war gut ich war ich war
okay ich war scheiße ich war echt
scheiße wenn euch das video vielleicht
trotzdem gefallen hat würde ich mich
über der bewertung freuen ich denke ich
wird es nie wieder hochladen wenn ihr es
trotzdem vielleicht wollt dann sagte sie
in den kommentaren egal ich bin jetzt
weckt mich das alles abarbeiten